i love the movie i think you did such a
great job with this and i really and i
really want to know i'm going to ask the
most important question up front
how the f did you get disney to let you
make this movie uh you know what you're
you're asking almost the wrong person
because i don't know what they were
saying behind closed doors but every
time they'd let us get a little further
we would all get a little more like kind
of giddy like okay all right
they're starting you know like hey
they're giving you know a couple hundred
grand to make a proof of concept like
that's how it started back in late 2019
i got the script late 2018 developed
with the writers for a year and then
they were like what will this look like
and so they gave us about a 200 000
budget and a team at npc and said why
don't you make like a 20-shot little
short that kind of shows the world and
shows like what does it look like to
have 2d 3d and we chose the scene with
um seth rogen's mocap guy with it so i
actually sent it to disney plus so
hopefully it'll be an extra i don't
think it'll be right when the movie
drops but they have it and it was a um
yeah it was just to show everybody kind
of the noir vibes i put in like a
warehouse with like broken windows and
like sunshine you know coming through
with dust and it's a version of the
scene that ended up in the movie just
for everybody to kind of see what it
would look like and that
i don't know that convinced them that it
was okay so well i'm specifically
talking about the fact that you were
able to get all these different
characters from disney and not disney
movies all like it's hard to do what you
did and getting all these different
companies to agree to lend out their ip
yeah well from the get go i kept talking
about and in meetings with disney people
how important it was to me to have third
party ip i remembered with you know your
t-shirt there who framed roger rabbit
which is obviously the gold standard of
this kind of movie how
amazing that was to all of us to see
those different
characters from different
animation worlds together finally with
daffy and donald and everything and
if this was gonna be
a love letter to animation a celebration
of animation within our modest budget
compared to say disney animated movies
or pixar movies within that then it has
to be all animation it can't just be
disney animation and so within that as
our goal and i kind of would give my
speeches to the legal team as well
trying to sell them on it and to be fair
they embraced the challenge and and
honestly the disney
legal team you know is owed a huge
amount of gratitude from me because it
wasn't easy when we would say the ones i
keep bringing up in interviews is like
my little pony because i don't want to
do any spoilers and or emcee scat guy
because those are in the trailer but
like you know it's easy enough for me
and and gregor and man or somebody to
those the writers to like write that in
or to get me to tell the storyboard
artists like hey make it my little
ponies but then these guys got to go
call mattel track down who did
friendship his magic version of it go
talk to them to make sure the rights
aren't split between like mattel and
some tv company and
netflix or whoever aired you know like
there are or what movie studio put out
the movie there's so many ways that
these rights get complicated and then if
they get a yes then it's you know we
have to pitch them the whole movie and
we have to show them where it'll fit in
it's a whole
show and then
can we use it in an ad you know every
detail has to be worked out and that's
for just one character in one shot
let alone then the poor animation team
needs to figure out ways
to try to
you know
anybody who works in animation knows
like a character that's only used for
one shot is the biggest you're not
amortizing costs correctly
so so it's in it's incredibly not cost
effective and especially when we're
starting our movies kind of experimental
so it has an experimental budget which i
didn't blame them for at all but it it
is what it is so it was a big challenge
for for everybody but i think everybody
kind of um
knew what we were attempting and kind of
got on board yeah um also what you did
is like it's a headache every step of
the way which is why so many people
don't do it because it's just such a
challenge you know um so i am curious um
which
which was the one that like really ended
up uh being the challenge to get into
the movie like who was the one that
really took the most convincing um i
don't know if you can say it without
spoiling yeah i don't i don't want to
well i i'm trying to nothing it jumped
into my head because the ones that were
really really difficult didn't end up in
the movie
and then we would choose other things
and sometimes you know how it is
if it's your first thought sometimes you
get it and it's like oh my god it
couldn't be better and sometimes when
somebody's like oh we can't get that
character and you think and then you
have to think again you think of
somebody else sometimes it's a blessing
in disguise
you know famously a lot of movies that
like like jaws being the most famous
like of where things don't work out but
it forces you to be more creative and
think of outside the box a little bit so
i don't even begrudge anybody that
you know wasn't didn't end up in the
movie
a lot of things rights are so especially
if they're from the 80s are so
convoluted people can't even quite
figure out who to ask or there's too
many parties you'd have to ask like it's
such a weird treasure
chase to try to even figure it out
um and then there were a lot of disney
characters we tried to put in where
disney was like
don't mess with that one so sometimes
you're seeing something being like
that's amazing but you don't realize it
was like our fifth choice not because it
was worse but because we had gone
through these different avenues to get
to where we ended up
um
yeah
but
yeah but but there was a lot of them i
don't make it all sound hard because
there was a lot of people and lawyers
and whoever they were and i don't even
know because where we would ask for
something like my little pony and it
just came back to me through the lawyers
and they're like yeah they're down it's
cool and it was like that easy for me
i would imagine that the disney
executives and the people that made this
are very happy with the way it turned
out and i know that people are gonna
love the movie when they see it this
weekend um and i'm just curious is it
some
did making this film and i rarely asked
this kind of stuff but are you
interested in like telling another story
where chip and dale are partnering up
with like other animated characters or
whatever it may be and doing more or you
sort of like okay this took years and
years of my life and i'm good i'm def
i'm open to more i don't know
it would be so different i've never
tried to make a sequel to anything and i
don't know how much
it makes it easier slash harder like
there's the obvious ways of like what's
the story and there's a reason sequels
usually are worse than the original
because they get rushed et cetera et
cetera but then there's also so much we
learned making this one that of things
that i look at and go oh we could have
done that better if we learned what we
learned in the last month could be
applied two years ago oh that could be
so much better and
some of the things i'm talking about
were like one-off characters or you know
like where you're like oh wow do you
start the second one with such a are you
so much further ahead on an animation
level because you have all this stuff
um
all the all the research and development
has already been done but just on a
creative level i'd be super open to it
although i have no idea what it would be
um right now but it does feel like the
world is limitless because there's so
many
different characters that could be
involved in different mysteries and
lethal weapon two is arguably better
than lethal weapon one so what are you
gonna so there's and bad boys too
maybe better than bad boys ones so uh
you gotta you've got a good tradition
going of this genre having a sequel that
can top the original so
uh you're 100 right lethal weapon two is
better and bad boys too is better
[Music]
those are the two main action
comedy
duo
touchstones for this movie in that
regard in terms of the live action genre
so
yeah i mean also like i look at roger
rabbit obviously which i love and you
know the what you did with this in terms
of how many characters i i can see so
many possibilities and you know um one
of the things i love about the movie is
that every background poster in every
frame i want to pause on because they
all make me laugh like they're all so
well done how
how did you pull like who was that all
scripted how did you come up with like
ever all those jokes it was in the dna
of the movie of like hey we're trying to
talk about a little bit of the like
uh commercialism of movies and it's in
the script of like
they pull into this neighborhood we see
posters for this and that and whether or
not that was the actual joke poster it
kind of just made it that it's in the
dna we are going to have billboards and
posters
not just on chip's little sad walk down
down vine street where he's looking at
them where it's really focused on but it
was like oh i see this can be everywhere
so
when we were filming and was like where
should they be driving it was also me
trying to find the most iconic la
neighborhoods so like if they're like
where should they be driving i'm like
can we get the sunset strip like the
core sunset strip
and when we could it was like it's also
just like a dream of mine as someone who
lives in l.a a lot of being like can we
shoot in all the most iconic la you know
la river the doc san pedro pier like the
ones that once you have shot there you
realize they're in every jason statham
movie you know and
uh even monty's apartment you know this
and how it's circular
if you i don't know how well you
remember lethal weapon one but that's
the international tower in long beach
you know the first shot and lethal
weapon with the helicopter shot and it's
the credits and then it circles a
building and finds goes in through the
window to find the girl
that's that building and so we made a cg
dollhouse size version of that building
like that's what his circular apartment
is and it even has the same
international tower of signage and when
ellie's on the street and she's leaning
in the window talking you know when
kiki's talking she's in front that is
the real location we really shot where
the international tower is
and then replaced the building with a
a mini version of the building
so i forget what your even question was
but
um
there's so many easter eggs like that
that no one will ever know if i don't
tell them you know what i mean sure well
actually that that's one of the things i
wanted to ask you is that are there like
really obscure in the background easter
eggs that you guys planted for people
that are going to push pause you know or
was it already like because you already
have so many i'm just curious yeah i
don't know about the pause thing you
might catch it when you're looking and
then have to but yes there are
definitely a bunch i just don't know how
many to give away it's like i feel like
i should let people discover them oh
wait i remember we were talking about
the movie posters and billboards the
last thing i'll say is there's this
woman olney atwell and she is a design
artist and she did
our editor on pop star knew her and she
does lots of different
real movies and comments i mean not that
comedy movies aren't real movies but
movies that aren't comedy but a lot of
comedy stuff and she did all the graphic
design for pop star so every time that
movie had tons of it whether it was
lower thirds just for people but also
the mags fake magazine covers all the
different things that you can imagine
you know
you know partywolves.com
you know when you have to yelp reviews
and every day in edit we had new ones of
like oh make me a rolling stone cover
that looks like this or you know so she
and she you know when you make a youtube
page you need to have all the fake
videos next to it what are they all of
of different connor videos and she's
really funny and would come up some of
that those are her jokes like the things
that are in pop star that you would
pause so the moment i started doing this
i was like we need to have her on for
like the whole post-production so every
day i could be like so the writers
brainstormed a ton of what could be the
fake movie posers then i did a ton and
then i just gave her this laundry list
and then was like go to town so every
day she would make like three new fake
template billboards like that could be
and then i would put them in and start
trying to find the right balance ones
that don't repeat jokes and blah blah so
it was a real process over a year of
post of like swapping billboards then
also legal would be like you can't do
that one you know so it's a real between
legal and comedy balancing it was a a
big task that's why i did want to shout
her out did you end up having a i always
ask about editing an amount of time but
i'm just gonna ask real quick did you
end up having like a longer cut and a
lot of deleted scenes or uh was it
pretty much uh what people are gonna say
you know if you saw my original animatic
there'd be a lot but because we had the
beauty of doing storyboards and
animatics and previz and then shooting
the stuff and then post vis and all that
all those layers by the time it gets to
like animation
you kind of are
very fairly close to where you are there
i did
maybe have edit spit out maybe eight
deleted
or extended scenes like chunks in a
scene that were pulled out
um and so those hopefully will end up on
disney plus i did turn them in but but
it's not as much as like pop star
obviously where we were just shooting
scene after scene at 45 minutes of like
real scenes these are just like oh this
scene could have had an extra 45 seconds
or things like that uh i could spend the
whole a [ __ ] hour talking about pop
star but anyway i'm out of time like you
just had asked another question before i
circled back to olney too that i didn't
answer but yeah you know it's okay i'm
just going to say that um congrats and i
know you have more interviews and also
we're going to talk saturday um and we
can and i cannot wait to talk
specifically about certain things well
i'm excited for the theater because
um
you know we made the movie knowing it
was disney plus but there was no we
didn't make it
like it was a streaming movie like we
color timed it in a movie theater the
way you do a movie and we sound
skywalker sounded the sound in the same
dub stage you would do a theatrical
movie so there was nothing about this
that had been was done
in a streaming way it was all done like
it was a theatrical movie we just are
putting it on i wish more people could
see it in the theater and i'm super
happy we're doing a screening on uh
saturday as i said man it's great i
really can't wait to see it in the
theater you know um good luck with the
rest of the interviews and i'll talk to
you soon yup thanks man